[Musique]
l'ordinateur est plus qu'une machine
il est le symbole de notre époque mais
il ne peut résoudre tous les problèmes
de la vie moderne celui de la
circulation dans nos villes géantes nord
américaine par exemple deviendrait
rapidement à soluble si des urbanistes
et des planificateurs ne s'y attaquer
résolument c'est ainsi qu'à montréal
vincent pauvres et ses collaborateurs
ont trouvé une solution
ils ont bâti un ensemble de rues et de
galeries souterraines climatisé qui
laisse loin derrière lui tout ce qui a
été fait dans le monde jusqu'à présent
[Musique]
le centre commercial des grandes villes
modernes n'occupe généralement qu'un
espace restreint et cela pour des
raisons économiques évidentes mais aussi
pour des raisons physiologiques
c'est pourquoi en amérique du nord le
centre commercial d'une grande ville
excèdent rarement 80 hectares toutefois
en appliquant une idée vieille de 500
ans celle de léonard de vinci qui
consiste à placer les véhicules et les
piétons à des niveaux différents
on parvient à utiliser le même terrain
plusieurs fois c'est ainsi qu'à montréal
lorsqu en 1957 nous avons su à notre
disposition les trois hectares des
chemins de fer nationaux du canada
nous ne nous sommes pas contentés d'y
ériger des gratte ciel nous avons permis
aux piétons de circuler sous terre
en 1962 les galeries souterraines sous
la place ville marie n'avait que 2 km de
long mais elle reliait déjà la gare
centrale et l'hôtel reine-elizabeth ou
cruciforme et la ville souterraine
comprenait un immense garage des cinémas
des restaurants et de nombreuses
boutiques
en 1967 avec l'ouverture de la place
bonaventure le réseau souterrain fut
porté à 6 km et il fut reliée au métro
il permet d'accéder à de nouveaux
at-elle l'hôtel bonaventure et le
château champlain et il relie entre
elles
les deux gars de montréal la ville
souterraine s'est aussi enrichie de
nombreuses boutiques et ce n'est qu'un
commencement si l'on en croit vincent
pente de nouveaux gratte ciel vont
s'élever au nord de la place ville-marie
et la ville souterraine actuelle verra
sa superficie triple exemple place ville
marie sera étendue vers le nord next
dans les dix prochaines années
ces galeries souterraines iront d'un
bout à l'autre du nouveau centre qui
sera axée sur l'avenue de l'université
mcgill
partant de la place ville-marie et
allant jusqu'au campus de l'université
de nouveaux édifices se dresseront de
chaque côté d'une promenade plantée
d'arbres avec des arcades comme rue de
rivoli à paris et des tours jumelles
ainsi qu'une place et deux bâtiments
moins élevés qui s'harmoniseront avec
ceux de l'université
ainsi en l'an 2000 lorsque montréal aura
non plus 2 millions et demi d'habitants
comme aujourd'hui mais 7 millions mais
cinq cent mille personnes qui surgiront
chaque jour de son métro de ces gares ou
de ces garages circulant à pied dans la
ville souterraine plus à l'aise mais mon
genre de pointe aujourd'hui sur les
trottoirs encombrés du centre de la
syrie
[Musique]